[Applause]
[Music]
Chechnya is an island of Islamic
fanaticism in the middle of Vladimir
Putin's Russia yup you heard that right
in the country that congratulate sit
self on being the spiritual shelter of
the West the last bulwark of
Christianity this is a country where you
can find the Republic of Chechnya it's a
part of Russia where it is impossible to
buy mod car oh yes and I know what
you're going to say are you waited in
assignment didn't you just say the
Republic of Chechnya didn't you say that
it was a part of Russia well the truth
is the Russian Federation is territory
wise the biggest country in the world
and that means that their political
distribution is really complicated the
biggest part of the country is divided
into the so called or blasts which are
similar to the states in the United
States of America these areas they have
their own governor they have their own
Parliament's but they must respect the
Russian Constitution as well as the
Kremlin however there are other regions
in Russia the so-called Republic's that
have way more autonomy they have their
own Constitution they have their own
language and they can even have their
own official religion one of these
Republic's is the Crimean Republic and
despite not being recognized by America
or by Europe it is controlled by Russia
you see in theory Russian law guarantees
a lot of autonomy Baths I say in theory
like that because as you know Vladimir
Putin loves to keep this country under
tight control in fact almost all of the
presidents of the Republic's belong to
Putin's political party and that would
be United Russia any time one of those
governors challengers Putin even just
the little things like this happen
Tatarstan the last region to lose its
special status under Putin nonetheless
there is a republic that Putin does not
dare to bully yep you heard that right
Vladimir Putin the Chuck Norris of
politics is afraid sometimes too
specifically when it comes to Chechnya
it is often unclear who rules whom
Russian observers of the region complain
that Russian law and authority stops at
the Chechnya border
[Music]
for example in Chechnya the hijab is
promoted by the government's things like
polygamy and even marriages involving
minors are actually tolerated and no
restaurant dares to open a day time
during Ramadan season nonetheless all of
these things are nothing compared to
what some newspapers showed in April of
2017 Chechnya opens world's first
concentration camp for homosexuals yeah
yeah listen I know Putin is not exactly
the biggest fan of LGBT rights but
opening a gay concentration camp sounds
like it it too much even for him so the
question to be made here is why doesn't
Putin put some order into Chechnya what
is the Chechen president Ramzan Kadyrov
secret to getting Putin to let him do as
he pleases well today we are going to
answer all of those questions but before
we do let's take a look back at the
history
the Sicily of the Caucasus fourth
centuries Chechnya was ruled by big
clans that had power over specific areas
those clans named took hung in the
chechen language were composed of
hundreds of smaller families the so
called teep for a better understanding
this was pretty similar to the Sicilian
Mafia system everything stayed in the
family
and everything was done according to the
principles of religion now in this case
Sunni Islam and the same way the
Sicilian Mafia resisted all kinds of
invasions the Chechen cooking system
survived the SARS and even the Soviet
Union must be Soviets in public and
Muslims in private
Chechnya proverb in other words during
the Soviet era there were two parallel
systems that were running at the same
time on the surface there was communism
that underground there was a hierarchy
of Muslim clans and families this is why
in the year 1991 when the Soviet Union
disappeared
Chechens seized the opportunity and
declared the Chechen Republic of a
carrier this name might ring about with
you because it appeared in one of the
call of duty video games now back then
the president of the brand-new Russian
Federation that was Boris Yeltsin and he
replied to those rebels with military
power Yeltsin declares emergency curfew
in Chechen region nevertheless of this
state of emergency failed entirely the
Russian army was incapable of stopping
the Chechen rebels and they had to run
back home but not only that during their
retreats the separatist rebels seized
Russian weapons so three long years the
Kremlin that put up with Chechnya but in
the year 1994 well things they changed
[Music]
you can build a throne with bayonets but
it's difficult to sit on it Boris
Yeltsin you met what I told you about
the political system of Chechnya which
was based on the tooken clan system well
the truth is those different clans
didn't really get on very well with each
other and this was the start of a civil
war a civil war that two Russian eyes
was the perfect opportunity to take back
control of the Republic however a year
later the Russian army had lost 6,000
soldiers and poor Boris Yeltsin had to
sign a peace treaty with the separatist
and pretty weak government of Chechnya
meanwhile many Islamic terrorists from
Saudi Arabia
and Afghanistan fled to Grozny the
Chechen capital to recruit new members a
failed state with a tribal system where
Islam is the official religion that
sounds like a pretty great market for
recruiting terrorists doesn't it
[Applause]
well in other words all of this meant
that it was just a matter of time before
another war began so this war it started
in 1999 when a group of Islamic rebels
invaded a neighboring Russian Republic
the Republic of Dagestan so if making
trouble in their own territory wasn't
enough Chechens wanted to attack other
parts of Russia now as you might imagine
from this the Kremlin decided to send
their troops immediately but this time
it was pretty different so why was this
well despite the fact Boris Yeltsin was
the president this time the Prime
Minister was the one and only the hero a
visual politic and that would be
Vladimir Putin
well Putin he actually went there and he
found one of these separatists Chiefs
and that would be mr.
akhmad Kadyrov so basically Pisan went
to this cataract eye and said alright
dude look I'm gonna show you in gold I'm
gonna give me as many weapons and as
much power as you need you could do
whatever you want there in Chechnya but
there is only one condition no Wars no
terrorism alright and as we say here at
visual politic as it was said well so it
was done the war it was over and CAD
refused all that help from the Kremlin
to destroy the other warlords in the
Republic
[Music]
and now you might be wondering well did
all of this work well the answers yes
and sort of also no of course there were
no more Wars but many of those other
warlords started organizing terrorist
attacks in other areas of Russia
including Moscow in the Moscow case a
terrorist group kidnapped over 300
hostages in a theater of those 300
civilians a hundred and seventy died in
other words Putin's plan was far from
perfect and cataratas Authority was not
taken for granted in fact some years
later he would die in another terrorist
attack in Grozny and well that was the
moment when the main character of this
story comes into the picture the
Instagram star Ramzan Kadyrov succeeded
his father in power and he learned a
valuable lesson if you want to start a
dictatorship you better make it big we
are talking about a country full of
warlords fighting each other where
al-qaeda or - are recruiting people who
might challenge cataratas power in other
words he was not willing to let those
weird Western fashions you know like
democracy or human rights make him look
weak besides he had PTIN support he had
wealth he had weapons what more could he
possibly ask for I owe my life to Putin
if I ever forget this I am NOT a man
when I went through a terribly hard time
in my life he helped he is the most
saintly man to me Ramzan Kadyrov
the truth is since catarah came to power
Chechen terrorists in other parts of
Russia while they've disappeared but not
only that al-qaeda and - militants are
disappearing - cata Rob's police chases
them expels them from the country with
their families and then burns down their
houses
[Music]
but if this was not enough cutter off
soldiers offer themselves as volunteers
for the most dangerous missions in
Ukraine in fact in order to show his
love for Putin
Ramzan camera of organized the military
parade at Cross knee football stadium
thousands of soldiers were waving at the
Chechen president ready to die for him
if Putin tells me to get my army
together I am ready rosna cutter off but
things well they are not as sweet as
they might seem actually with that
military parade catarah was giving two
messages one was hey Putin I'm your
buddy but the other was hey Putin if you
ever stop being my buddy come and get me
if you dare yes dear viewer if Vladimir
Putin ever wanted to confront his
Chechen bestie it would be complicated
to say the least
[Music]
and there are many signs this could
actually happen in fact all of cataratas
political foes they've been murdered
regardless of where they were from
journalists living in Moscow two
political opponents hiding in some
petersburg they've all been killed so
what does this mean well it means the
government of Grozny has its own KGB
situated all across the country
and well they're happy to use it anytime
someone Chechen or not gets a little
bit's bothersome so put it more
poetically while Putin created Ramzan
Kadyrov and now his creation has become
big enough to look him in the eyes
this explains why unlike other
presidents of Russian republics catarah
dares to give his opinion on
international affairs and the Kremlin
they pretend they don't see those
horrific gay concentration camps Russia
backs Chechnya government's denials over
killing and torture of gay men meanwhile
Chechnya is getting wealthier and
wealthier thanks to Russia 90% of their
wealth comes direct from money transfers
from the Kremlin cut her off
he's built a republic where the cult of
aspersion ality is almost like a second
religion just surpassed by Islam his
Instagram account by the way has over 3
million followers which is twice as many
as the Chechen population and on this
account you can see the lifestyle of one
of the craziest dictators around and at
the same time the only one that makes
Putin afraid
[Applause]
[Music]
so now the question is will Vladimir's
in and ramzan kadyrov ends up clashing
should the Kremlin try to stop the human
rights violations in Chechnya well
please leave your answer in the comment
section below and also visit the
reconsider Media podcast the podcast
that provided the vocals in this video
that are not mine also don't forget that
we publish brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button and you will not miss a post and
if you liked this video give it a thumbs
up and as always I'll see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]